dans les chéris bruno masure alors bruno
masure je m'explique je vous parlais
d'une sombre histoire en effet il ya eu
un petit imbroglio complètement
rocambolesque avec bruno masure et moi
même par bruno masure c'est l'ancien
présentateur du jt de france du rialet
cette histoire a eu lieu sur twitter on
a fait un petit résumé
regardez je vous donne la réponse juste
après c'est parti mardi 9 janvier 2018
10h20 du matin l'ex présentateur du jt
bruno masure publié sur twitter une
photo d'un sms que lui aurait envoyé
cyril hanouna l'animateur pakistano
tunisien de ses huit aurait dit aux
journalistes qui ne présentait plus rien
qu'il n'était plus rien qu'il devait se
remettre en question et qu'il n'était
qu'une petite bouille
l'ex animateur du jt conseil alors à
baba de retourner à l'école primaire
un peu plus tard dans la matinée cyril
hanouna dément l'information sur les
réseaux sociaux et explique qu'il n'a
jamais envoyer ses messages
l'animateur star de ces 8 assure que
bruno masure n'avait tout simplement pas
le bon numéro
l' affaire aurait pu s'arrêter là mais
non bruno masure et un investigateur
hors pair assure que le numéro qui lui a
envoyé le message est bien celui de
monsieur cyril hanouna qui a tort qui a
raison qui est bruno masure autant de
questions auxquelles l'inspecteur baba
va tenter de répondre et donc de vous
pour une voiture voulait voir ses
bannières et donc in à m'envoyer un sms
sur un portable mon ancien portable et
il est persuadé que c'était moi donc il
a dit je n'ai rien contre
il a dit voilà que donc c'était moi que
voilà qu'il fallait que en fait qui a
dit oui
hanouna qui n'assume jamais ces
conneries fait croire à ses fans zoosk
réduit les inconditionnels qui ne m'a
jamais envoyé de sms à la con en bon
journaliste j'ai vérifié il ment
évidemment mais ça n'a aucune importance
juste la médiocrité et bien les chéris
sachez que la personne qui a mon numéro
maintenant je la connais et elle est là
ce soir
et oui et applaudissements
il se compte que cette personne qui a
récupéré mon numéro s'appelle cyril si
vous vivez l'enfer parce qu'il ait
réussi à avoir mon numéro par des
contacts et il me dit qu'il vit l'enfer
depuis maintenant huit mois huit mois
quand les gens vous appelle tout le
temps et donc bruno masure vous envoyez
un sms
oui et qu'est ce qui vous a pris de
répondre à ma place je suis jamais
pourquoi votre place ouais j'en vois que
je veux juste faire toujours tous les
mails sms soit vous ou à loïc
oui la vie et il a commencé par des
insultes ouais donc donc vengé l'insulté
ah oui vous est pris pour moi vous avez
là une petite couilles tout ça voilà mes
produits qui a commencé puisque oui oui
ça ah oui voilà d'accord j'ai
surenchérit d'accord voilà pourquoi mais
la famille ce qui vous a pris en faisait
dix-sept fois ci il m'a énervé je me
faire passer pour cyril non c'est
l'injustice walla s'est inventé un texto
par un par une insulte sa masse et à ta
mère c est pas moi non plus je te merde
il a pas mis ta mère serait donc voilà
donc vous nous confirmez donc marino
voilà donc ces annuités envoyer tous
mais si peu et j'ai le téléphone là ce
qu'il veut faire il peut l'année il peut
t'aider finale
donc voila voila bruno donc tu vas
reprendre un petit potin stage de
journalisme et uranus
la mairie leur avait refusé d'appeler
filet c'est mon ancien numéro une forte
mer des séries merci nous